happier times
[Music]
a newly elected prime minister ushering
in the chinese new year
and a new era of cooperation with this
global power
but much has changed in a few short
months tensions are mounting
over china's handling of the coronavirus
pandemic
its brutal crackdown on the people of
hong kong
and the uk's decision to exclude huawei
from britain's 5g network
the once wanted golden era of uk china
relations
looking rather tarnished under this pm
i'm
not going to be sort of pushed into a
position of becoming
a knee-jerk cyanophobe on every issue
somebody who is automatically
anti-china but we do have serious
concerns we have concerns about the
treatment of the the uyghur
minority obviously about the human
rights abuses we
obviously have concerns about
what's happening in hong kong those
concerns lead into action the foreign
secretary suspending the uk's
extradition treaty with hong kong
and halting the export of weapons to the
former uk territory
we will protect our vital interests we
will stand up for our values
and we will hold china to its
international obligations
labour offering qualified support this
must mark the start
of a more strategic approach to china
based on an ethical approach to foreign
policy and an end to the naivety of the
golden era years
and if it does he can be assured that he
will have our full support on this side
of the house
and an end to naivety demanded by mps on
the government's
own side too with the policy of the
golden
era it was the hope that china would
change
but in actual fact that's turned out to
be incorrect
so now we need to deal with the reality
that china hasn't changed
and in fact if anything has gone in the
other direction so now we need to ask
ourselves the question
do we now need to tie these two things
together trade at the same time as
change in china
with relations between beijing and
washington at their lowest ebb in
decades the u.s secretary of state will
use a two-day visit to the uk
to keep the pressure up global britain
trying to develop an
independent foreign policy but caught
between two super powers instead
beth rigby sky news westminster